Speaker 1: Joe Biden has tested positive for
COVID again. He has absolutely no symptoms,
is isolating out of an abundance of
caution. But it is believed that this is
this sort of like rebound positivity. There are
some claims it could be related to the medication.
Pax livid that PAX a little bit helps you get
over the virus, but then may be related to
testing positive. Again, I'm not saying
that definitively. That's one bit
of. That's one claim that's being
evaluated. But the belief is that this is a
not clinically significant testing positive again.
Now, the former president, Donald Trump, believes
that this is actually the wrong diagnosis,
that Trump that Biden was diagnosed with COVID,
but actually the right diagnosis is dementia.
This is a real post from a former president on his
social media platform Truth, Social Trust Central.
And Donald Trump said the following, quote,
Joe Biden's second bout of COVID,
sometimes referred to as the China
virus, was sadly misdiagnosed by his doctors.
He instead has Capital D dementia but is happily
recovering well. Well, at least he's recovering
from the dementia. That's good. Joe is thinking
of moving part time to one of those beautiful
Wisconsin nursing homes where almost 100%
of the residents, miraculously, and for the first
time in history, had the strength and energy to
vote, even if those votes were cast illegally.
Get well soon, Joe. This is a former. This is
an outrageously demented comment. If you want to
talk about dementia, that's a demented comment.
But one of the fascinating things about it is
that unless you're following the right wing sort
of grievance machine, as David Roberts called it,
you don't even know what Trump's talking about.
David Roberts runs the newsletter Volts about
clean energy. Great newsletter he posted about
Trump's truth social post about Biden's COVID
dementia. Something pretty astute, he said. The
right wing grievance machine has become so insular
and baroque that it sounds like they're speaking
another language. You have to immerse yourself
in the right wing bubble for years to even follow
along. And that's absolutely true. To understand
what Donald Trump is even referring to in that
completely unhinged post, you have to have been
following Trump's lies and conspiracy theories
for several years. There's like three inside
scam references. You have to understand one.
It's this whole thing of calling COVID, the China
virus, 99 point whatever percent of the world
refers to it as COVID or coronavirus. There
is this group of people that follow Trump
that call it the China virus. It's a Republican
Trumpian thing. You've got to understand that.
Number two, Biden dementia. That's another thing
that Donald Trump has increasingly been talking
about and saying Joe doesn't even know where he is
and all this sort of stuff. And then, three, the
voter fraud in Wisconsin nursing homes. The idea,
there's two versions of that. One version is the
nursing homes had 100% turnout. And that doesn't
make sense. It's also not true. They didn't.
And the second version is the nursing homes voted
100% for Joe Biden. And that doesn't make sense.
That's also not true. It's another Republican
lie, another Republican scam. So understand how
if you don't follow the right wing scams and you
just say, oh, Trump's not on Twitter, let's see
what he posts on Truth Social. You would read that
and have absolutely no idea what on earth Donald
Trump is talking about. It's their own language
at this point. They live in their own world,
and that is not a normal thing for a former
president of the United States to post
the form that the current president has. COVID
misdiagnosed. It's actually dementia. That is
insane. But in modern day 2022, it doesn't feel
that surprising. It's the type of stuff Trump's
been saying for a very long time. Crazy, crazy.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.